Today,
we turned to one of two introductory
cases where promise service who entered
into seemingly valid contracts attempt
to avoid liability for not following
through on their promises.
Today's case,
Bolin farm's versus American cotton
shippers association involves a futures
contract for the sale of cotton.
In the first few months of 1973 11
cotton farmers in western Louisiana.
Among them,
Bolin farm's signed contracts
with American cotton
shippers to sell cotton grown
on their farms at harvest time that year.
Those contracts locked in prices between
29 and 41 cents per pound while the
market price of cotton at that time
range between 28 and 32 cents per pound,
but commodity markets
can change quite rapidly.
By the time the farmers were
harvesting their cotton in September,
cotton prices had more than doubled
to around 80 cents per pound.
The deals they had gotten before of up
to 41 cents per pound no longer seem so
good,
and the f so the farmers
sued for a declaration that
the contracts are null and
void unquote so that they could sell for
a better price than they bargained for.
The suit came before the Federal District
Court for the western district of
Louisiana and the court had to decide
whether a future contracts remain valid
even when the market price becomes
very different from the contract price.
Common law court opinions have
changed over time about whether change
circumstances can affect a party's
obligations under a contract.
The old rule is that packed as soon
Servon de agreements are to be honored.
Most famously,
the English Court of Kings Bench said
in Paradine v Jane in 1647 that when the
party by his own contract creates
a duty or charge upon himself,
he's bound to make it good if he may not
withstanding any accident by inevitable
necessity because he might have
provoked against it by his contract.
That is no matter how circumstances have
changed since the contract was signed.
If a party cannot fulfill her promise,
she must compensate the
other party to the contract.
The rules have become somewhat
more lenient over time.
One typical approach is found in section
two six 15 of the uniform commercial
code which says nondelivery by a seller
is not a breach of his duty under a
contract for sale if performance is
agreed has been made impracticable by the
occurrence of a contingency.
The non occurrence of which was a basic
assumption on which the contract was
made.
If the parties made their agreement
based on an assumption about the world,
that turns out to be false.
That could relieve a party of the
responsibility to follow through on the
promise,
but possible changes in the world that
parties were aware of when they formed
the contract will not
invalidate the contract.
Note that the uniform commercial code
itself does not apply in this case,
Louisiana,
Louisiana is one of the states is the,
is the one state that has not
adopted a article two of the UCC.
Generally,
Louisiana laws often different from
that of other states because it retains
elements of the French Civil Code Law
from when it was a French colony before
the Louisiana purchase of 1803 in the
case of Bolin farm's judge hunter found it
quite easy to determine
that the contract is valid.
The entire purpose of a futures contract
is to hedge against possible future
changes in the price of the
underlying good or commodity.
The farmers entered into the contract
knowing that if the price of cotton fell,
they would make money on the contract
because they could sell it the agreed upon
future price instead of the market price.
They also knew that if
the price of cotton rows,
they would miss out on a higher market
price or spot price at harvest time in
signing the contract,
they locked in a particular future
price for going both the possible future
gains and future losses.
They cannot now abrogate their agreement
simply because it turns out to be less
favorable than selling that
the higher spot market price.
They would not have wanted the American
cotton shippers association to do that
if the prices had fallen.
I've included this case to show you that
not all contract disputes are difficult.
The result in Bolton farm chords
with most people's common sense.
So here's a quiz. Suppose that instead
of rising to 80 cents per pound,
the price of continent
fallen to 10 cents per pound.
Now the American copper cotton shippers
association wants to have the contract
declared void so they can
buy cheaper cotton elsewhere.
How will the court rule?
Well,
just as the farmer could not evade their
obligation to sell the contract to sell
there their cotton at the agreed upon
price. When the market price rose,
the American copper cotton shippers
association cannot evade its obligation to
buy the farmers cotton at the agreed
upon price when the market price falls.
So the contract will be held to be valid.
The parties are mutually bound
to this, uh, reciprocal bargain.
But this kind of price mutuality is
not a mandatory part of all contracts.
Option contracts explicitly
give the option holder, uh,
price protection, but the
option of trading at a more
favorable spot price. Thus,
the farmers might have merely purchased
put options to sell their cotton at
particular forward prices,
but they would have had to pay for that
asymmetric option from Bolin farm's we
have learned about the impact change
circumstances can have on a contract.
We'll come back to this when we study
in practicum impracticability again,
the general rule remains the
same as it's been for centuries.
Parties to a contract are responsible for
filling their promises or compensating
the other side if they,
if they breach.
We saw that this has been
loosened somewhat by the
UCC section two six 15 which
allows parties to evade their promises
if fundamental assumptions underlying the
contract turned out to be impracticable.
However,
since losing money on a futures
contract as happens in Bolin,
farm's is certainly not the kind of
thing that is enough to invalidate the
farmer is obligation.
By the way,
the farmers also raised a question about
whether they were somehow victims of
buyer insider information,
superior information.
The court rejected the allegation.
As a factual matter,
cotton buyers don't have much opportunity
to learn about weather or the boll
weevil infestations ahead of time,
but we'll be returning to the question
of whether buyers or sellers have a duty
to disclose a superior
information later in the course,
especially when we discuss the
supreme court's decision in Laidlaw.